hello everybody my name is markiplier
and we're in the final stretch of the
expert levels of Super Mario maker and
then maybe just maybe I can lay this
challenge
to rest whoa whoa I was supposed to ride
that I was supposed to ride that that's
what I was supposed to do I was supposed
to ride that oh I get it
I don't know where it's gonna take me
from here but I'm going to stay on this
because I am a good boy do it to me no
those things were slippery Plus Mario's
greasing up his feet
okay 38 lives left it's really down to
the wire here I mean it may seem like a
lot but considering I lost 20 lives on
one level before I'm not gonna take any
chances I'm not gonna take any chances
okay do me do me again do me again I
know the feeling just thinking about my
potential for failure here is really
given me good me was with Danny call it
love you anything to do with that good
God okay that's good two levels left huh
well that don't look good I don't know
what to do about that holy [ __ ] Oh God
okay here we go oh god that's not what I
wanted that's not what I wanted okay
I'm alive I got a spring I don't know
this was supposed to do
well the [ __ ] is going on up here what
is this [ __ ]
thank you thank you for this thank you
never get a granddad okay I thought it
was about to lie to me
okay dig this deep thank you get-get-get
thank you okay
whoa whoa whoa whoa what are you doing
that's not fair
oh I know how to do this oh it's not
that bad but it still hurts guys still
hurts my feelings oh what a load of but
blast what a butt blasting oh god damn
it if I'm not going fast and oh [ __ ]
okay so I just gotta take this a running
okay we got it we got it okay I'm gonna
get a mosh here it's all gonna be good I
can just drop down here no biggie
go through the turtle area cuz the
turtle area seems to be the winner wait
for them to finish their crap almost
done you're gonna be okay good not [ __ ]
again with I gotta wait again okay oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you okay set you
down here just in case just in case
things go wrong
yeah okay things are probably not gonna
go wrong but I always like to plan for
the worst [ __ ] don't do that oh there's
two yeah we're here Kay good thing I
left this oh they're all back well
that's good big old bag Nix how many
more we got
oh yes and I get someone ups whoa I'm
going to the last level with 40 lives 40
lives oh my god I'm gonna do it guys
this whole session started off a little
wonky but here we go 40 lives for the
last level I can do oh god no oh god no
okay I just got to get through this Wow
oh [ __ ] okay that's fine just went a
little too fast on that it's fine
oh lordy if I fail this on the very end
here I knew it was too good to be true
with getting those easy-peasy levels
oh that's coming over for me that's
gonna touch me in the bum bum okay it's
gonna be fine cuz I know how to beat
this oh man the momentum is a [ __ ]
there man that momentum is just a sack
of [ __ ] oh man if this castle was just
designed a little bit smarter wouldn't
be such a pile of dicks whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa okay [ __ ]
oh god I'm already six lives down Oh God
I'm getting flashbacks oh why why didn't
I go as high oh good lordy Lou okay so I
just gotta jump
to do okay easy-peasy I can do this
simple jump supposed to be able to do
that are you kidding me [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] this I mean of course it gives
me two easy ones because it wants me to
have a false sense of security about
things and then just when I'm feeling
happy
I just after I it's because it's got
happiness sensors and it heard that I
was happy and I told you guys that was
happy
ah [ __ ] I guess I could spin jump the
left way oh man oh man
it's got happiness sensors and I guess
Jojo is just an alias for Ross okay [ __ ]
you that's the only way that I can think
to beat the momentum is just spin
jumping no how how are you supposed to
do that seriously how like what ha how
are you supposed to do that
I'm disheartened because I
guys it's not fair guys it's not fair oh
that was my fault but Wow what are you
kidding me it's not fair what the [ __ ]
okay okay okay I don't want I don't want
whatever's down there whatever's down
there is not worth it
this seems like it was made by a Ross
type this this level seems like just
[ __ ] Ross all over it
whoa whoa what the what the [ __ ]
happened what the [ __ ] was that what are
you kidding me
oh my god why did that happen okay so
far so goo okay
just run across here okay
oh that is that is just dick a tree that
is just [ __ ] tree
you [ __ ] [ __ ] whoever made this
level is a goddamn [ __ ] it's it's not
fair after every it's not fair
oh no twenty four lives left twenty four
lives left are you kidding me
I can't waste a single one I cannot
waste a single one oh you can't see that
I can't are you kidding me I don't know
that's their [ __ ] off 20 lives left 20
lives left No whoa man what the hell
what the hell man criminy Christmas I
did the shortest oh no no no no this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] that level I don't care
what you show me I don't care what you
do I will not be [ __ ] over I will not
be [ __ ] over
I refuse to be [ __ ] over I refuse it I
refuse I will not I will not I will not
okay okay okay okay okay no no you
random chance piece of [ __ ]
if that's what you're gonna make this
level about then [ __ ] you okay we're
getting back to this one if it's if it's
another random chance I'm skipping this
level too because holy [ __ ]
it better not be [ __ ] off yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes
ah there's everyone who contributed to
the levels probably even the ones that I
skipped I might early regret that I had
to skip the last one but I just didn't
want to fail I was heartbroken I was
heartbroken at the end there I was just
feeling sorrow in the pit of my soul it
was bad it was bad but we did it I'm is
gonna be very clear I don't think I'm
ever gonna do the Supra
oh it's only six levels ok maybe then
but I don't think so for now I think
I've played Mario maker for a long time
now and I've accomplished something that
I wanted to do I do feel good that I got
through that and holy [ __ ] you saw I was
trying hard on that last one but man I
was not good enough at wall jumps wall
jumps are like my one weakness and
goddammit of course in the last level
there's some random chance but
thankfully it wasn't more than that and
I got through that perfectly I've never
concentrated so hard in my life so thank
you everybody so much for watching thank
you for sticking with me through this
entire time thank you for supporting me
through the entire journey that I took
on Super Mario maker thank you for being
there with me in the radius moments and
the happiest joyous successes thank you
so much for being here with me the whole
way through this has been a [ __ ] ride
but thank you guys so I'm really
seriously I'm very grateful for you guys
for joining me here it has been a wild
ride I don't know if I'm gonna try super
expert cuz I don't know if my heart can
take it but thank you guys again so much
for watching and thank you for enjoying
it I really hope you did let me know if
you did in the comments below
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video